مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره مع انا عبيد
[موسيقى]
نفاع احكي بابرز تطورات اللي صارت خلال
الاسبوع الماضي بعالم كره القدم وابرز
تطور حسب وجهه نظري هو هاري ماجواير هاري
ماجواير اللغز المحير في مانشستر يونايتد
هو اللاعب اللي يعني على مدار سنوات طويله
اربع سنوات تقر تريبا مع اليونايتد كان
ماده اعلاميه دسمه جدا للسخريه والتهكم
وما الى ذلك ولكن خلال اسبوعين فقط تحول
هاري ماجواير من ها الماده اللي حكينا
عنها لبطل في اولد ترافورد ليش لانه
ماجواير لعب ثلاث مباريات مع اليونايتد
ورا بعض ابتداء من برانتفورد شيفيلد
وكوبنهاجن في دوري الابطال وفي الثلاث
مباريات قدم مستويات جيده جدا لا بل انه
تقييمه ما نزل عن البعه من وكان حاسم
ونقطه قوه مهمه جدا لمانشستر يونايتد هذا
الجميل في كره القدم ببعض الاحيان انه
ببساطه الناس بتنسى لك اخطائك كلها بتنسى
لك مشاكلك وبترجع بتعتبر بطل ولاعب مهم
جدا ولاعب ممتاز جدا بثلاث او اربع
مباريات بتقدم فيها اداء جيد بشكل متوسط
لكن قبل ما نتسرع ونحكم على مستوى ماجواير
لازم نعرف انه ما لعب امام الفرق الست
الكبرى بانجلترا حتى الان ولا حتى لعب
امام فرق مثل نيو كاسل او استون فيلا ولكن
هذا ما بينفي انه في تطور بالمستوى فعلا
وفي اداء جيد كان باخر ثلاث مباريات طيب
شو السبب وراء هذا الموضوع السبب من وجهه
نظري هو انه ماجواير حس بالخطر لانه على
مدار السنوات الاربعه الماضيه ماجواير كان
حاسس بالحمايه او الحصانه بسبب المبلغ
الكبير اللي اجا فيه على مانشستر يونايتد
وكان شايف انه الاداره صعب انها تتخلى عنه
ورح تتمسك فيه لاخر لحظه على امل انه يعمل
شيء ويعوض المصاري اللي اندفعت فيه
والمدربين ايضا بالتبعيه ما راح ي يعزلو
او يحاولوا انهم ما يعتمدوا عليه لنفس
السبب ولكن ما حدث الصيف الماضي لما شفنا
انه ماجواير كان قريب من الانتقال لويست
هام وشفنا انه اداره يونايتد مستغنيه الى
حد ما عن اللاعب ماجواير شعر بالخطر
وبالتالي بلش يحاول يحسن بنفسه اكثر واكثر
ولكن مشكله ماجواير يعني ال تفسيرين او
تحليلين مهمين جدا اول تحليل انه هذا
اللاعب هو لاعب يعني لا مبالي كسول ما
بيشتغل على انه يطور نفسه ما بيشتغل على
انه يحسن من نفسه اكثر واكثر ولا حاحاول
يبذل مجهود كبير بتطوير الذات في عالم كره
القدم لانه اللي بيطلع على مسيرته مع
اليونايتد من 2019 حتى اليوم بشوف انه
اللاعب ما تطور يعني ما شفنا انه ماجواير
اشتغل على نقاط معينه فنيا بنفسه كان
بالسرعه ولا ان كان بالتحكم ولا ان كان
بالتمريرات او بالتمركز او بالقراءه تحسنت
او تطورت على على مدى السنوات الماضيه
وبالتالي هذا قد يدل على انه اللاعب كسول
ولكن الغلط مش بس عليه الغلط ايضا على
المدربين لانه ما كان في مدرب بيونايتد من
2019 حتى اليوم مدرب مستقر موجود بشكل
دائم لمده مثلا موسمين ثلاث مواسم اربع
مواسم قادر انه يشتغل بشكل فردي على
ماجواير ويطور له من نقاط ضعفه ويحسن له
ايضا نقاط قوته ويشتغل عليها وهذا الامر
ظلم ماجواير اكثر واكثر وساهم بكسله او
بانه ما يشتغل على نفسه وما يكون مهتم
بالموضوع التحليل الثاني انه مغواير بسبب
عدم تركيزه داخل ارضيه الملعب وفي يمكن
عنده حاله من فقدان التركيز بتصيب خلال
المباراه بتخليه يخطا اخطاء ساذجه هي
الاخطاء وبسبب هي الاخطاء وعدم التركيز
عرضته لمشاكل وانتقادات
بتكون يعني مش واضحه او مش ظاهره للجمهور
ولكن تكرر الاخطاء وارتكاب اخطاء كبيره
وساذج بشكل متواصل هذا الشيء خلاه يتحول
لماده للسخريه على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي الشاهد بالحالتين انه ماجواير
ان كان بالحاله الاولى فهو بيتحمل جزء من
المسؤوليه وان كان بالحاله الثانيه فهو
ايضا بيتحمل جزء من المسؤوليه لانه
ماجواير بهي الضغوطات وبسبب ه الضغوطات
يعني تحول للاعب خايف نازل على الملعب
دائما متوتر مع مانشستر يونايتد واللي
بقدم له دليل على هذا الموضوع هو اداؤه
الجيد مع منتخب انجلترا اللي بتحسه لما
بيلعب مع انجلترا متخلص من الضغوطات متخلص
من الخوف ومتخلف من كل المشاكل اللي بعاني
منها مع مانشستر يونايتد الامر الايجابي
في هاري ماغواير بالحالتين انه هو لاعب
عنده الشجاعه يواجه الضغوطات وعنده
الشجاعه انه يضله مع مانشستر يونايتد رغم
كل الانتقادات ورغم كل الهجوم اللي تعرض
له على مدار السنوات الماضيه وهذا الامر
بدل على انه لاعب عنده الجراه وعنده
الشجاعه ولكن النقطه الاخرى الاهم من ذلك
انه ماجواير تقبل فكره سحب شاره القياده
منه بصدر رحب وتقبل ايضا فكره مهمه جدا
انه يكون على دكه البدلاء وهذا امر ما
بيتقبل اي لاعب وما بيهتم او ما بيتحملوا
اي لاعب بالدوريات الخمسه الكبرى وخصوصا
اذا كان جاي بمبلغ كبير على نادي كبير مثل
مانشستر يونايتد وتحت دائره الضوء الان
ماجواير بالختام طبعا ماجواير هو لاعب انا
شخصيا تابعته من كاس العالم 2018 وتابعت
اداؤه مع ليستر قبل 2019 ب27 و18 وشفت انه
هذا اللاعب عنده قدرات هائله وممكن يكون
واحد من افضل مدافعي العالم والمبلغ اللي
اندفع فيه كان منطقي في ذلك الحين ولكن
لازم يشتغل على نفسه اكثر يطور من موضوع
التركيز عنده يطور من عقليته ومن قدرته
على التعامل مع الامور ويحاول انه يشتغل
على نفسه بالامور الفنيه اكثر واكثر وايضا
تن هاج لازم يتحمل مسؤوليه بهذا الامر
ولازم يشتغل على انه يطور مستوى ماجواير
لانه في كثير لاعبين شفناهم مع مدربين
كانوا سيئين جدا ولكن لما اجا مدرب اخر
اشتغل على نقاط قوته وحسن من نقاط ضعفه
اللاعب تطور بشكل مذهل وصار واحد من افضل
لاعبي العالم هذا كان كل شيء بحلقه الوم
بعد الصافره حتى نلتقي الاسبوع المقبل
كونوا بالف
خير y